dear moisture for game, I believe that in the current situation we are simply obliged to act in this way, Nikolay Platonovich would agree with the proposal and that our Western partner, so to speak, can be given the last chance in order to offer them to force Kyiv to go to peace as soon as possible and fulfill the Minsk agreements otherwise we must take the decision that is being said today otherwise you propose to start the negotiation process no I either under or and or recognize their oppression they are shaved I speak when I speak directly I will support the proposals for recognition I will support or support speak directly today live proposals and say so the secret currency I support the proposal the entry of the Donetsk and Luhansk people's republics the composition of the Russian Federation we are talking about this we are not talking about this we are not discussing we are talking about the recognition of their independence and the line yes I support the proposal recognition of independence well drive
Thank you
Vladimirovich